tristan thompson just confirmed he
fathered a third child and made a public
apology to his ex khloe kardashian now a
source tells e.t how the keeping up with
the kardashians star is doing amid the
drama i'm focused on taking care of me
my body and soul and true e.t source
explains that the 37 year old has been
doing her best to stay positive take
care of herself both mentally and
physically and continue to make her
biggest priority her three-year-old
daughter true whom she shares with the
nba star
quote chloe and tristan are in touch
about logistical things and about what's
going on with true and that's really the
focus when they're communicating that's
how it should be on monday tristan
confirmed he is the father of a now
month-old baby the result of a
short-lived affair with a woman named
marlene nichols along with the
confirmation came an apology to chloe
whom tristan was in a relationship with
when he slept with mara lee quote chloe
you don't deserve this you don't deserve
the heartache and humiliation i have
caused you you don't deserve the way i
have treated you over the years my
actions certainly have not lined up with
the way i view you i have the utmost
respect and a love for you regardless of
what you may think again i am so
incredibly sorry e.t source says the 30
year old pro athlete has been apologetic
and has been attempting to make things
better
according to court docs obtained by the
daily mail tristan's third child was
conceived in houston during his 30th
birthday celebration in march at the
time of his birthday chloe shared these
family pics of tristan and true at his
party calling him her quote best friend
in the caption quote the ones that are
meant to be are the ones who go through
everything that is designed to tear them
apart and they came out even stronger
than they were before the good american
founder added quote thank you for
showing me everything you said you would
for the father you are for the best
friend i have in you but things turned
sour after that the two split in june
amid allegations that the athlete had
once again been unfaithful fans of
keeping up with the kardashians will
recall the former couple first split in
february 2019 amid his cheating scandal
with kylie jenner's former bestie jordan
woods you know things happen and of
course i'm sorry and apologetic as much
as i can be the make-out sesh marked the
second time he had been unfaithful to
coco back in 2018 reports surfaced that
tristan cheated on her with multiple
women while she was pregnant with true
despite it all the two managed to
co-parent their little girl through the
ups and downs i think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style it's a beautiful thing
to get along with each other and for
your kids to see that they later
rekindled their romance while
quarantining together amid the pandemic
and following their split a source told
et in september that tristan still quote
tries to get chloe back adding quote
chloe gave tristan several chances and
after new allegations decided it was
time to break things off the two are on
good terms and at the end of the day
chloe just wants true to have a good
relationship with her father so how does
coco's famous family feel about it all
ity soar says they're sticking by her
side and trying to uplift her quote they
will always be respectful of tristan as
will chloe since he's the father of true
[Music]
you